our next speaker
has
moved
i want to know the time frame
has moved 28 times across nine states
i have questions like are these small
states or big states how many times in
each state how many time over what time
period this was were you being chased
out by pitchfork
so uh we have lots of questions that we
may or may not get answered from lauren
hi everyone uh i'm so excited to be here
today uh
sharing some of the research i've
recently done
with microsoft's worldwide public sector
team on uh how to implement effective
government platforms
before i start i'll answer one of those
questions which is the 28 moves is
across 27 years so lots of moving um
and we'll leave the rest of the details
a mystery for now
um
i'm lauren lombardo i'm a graduate
research uh fellow at the harvard
kennedy school where i've been studying
uh technology policy and digital
government and a variety of ways to
improve the way that government delivers
services using uh improved technical
systems
and modern technology and as part of
that work one of the things i've spent a
lot of time on
is thinking about government platforms
uh
specifically
what
should government platforms be thought
of how should governments think about uh
using developing and implementing
platforms uh is that different than
private sector platforms uh and once the
government decides that they want to use
platforms or platform ecosystems to
better provide service delivery
uh how should they go about doing that
what are some of the big questions that
they're going to have to have answers to
uh and who are they going to have to
convince
uh so with that i'll i'll go straight
into the presentation uh and i am always
happy and willing to talk about this so
if folks have questions uh or want to
sort of chat more about this after the
conference i would be very interested in
that and happy to do so
uh to start this research really
centered on the idea that governments
need to have a shared language for what
they think platforms are and how they
would want to build uh platforms in a
government
ecosystem
government platforms i found in this
research are not really a new concept
in 1086
william the conqueror
documented the people and land and
buildings in england and sort of created
this national registrar that was used
for tax purposes and that's pretty
broadly considered to be one of the
first government platforms
obviously not what we would think of as
platforms today but
as we start to think about how
governments implement more digital type
platforms
some of the same principles apply having
some core components that we build
things on top of having some reusable
systems um
and having real policy
input locations for how services are
delivered and how people interact with
the government
uh also governments can receive a lot of
benefits from using platforms we've seen
this to be true in the private sector uh
but these benefits are really
contingent upon how the platform is
built uh and it's really important for
developers and policymakers to both have
a similar and clear
uh vision for what government platforms
should look like
that would allow them to have really
specific conversations about what the
government needs uh and what should be
built and
how
so that being said uh the first thing
that we said in this research was really
think about how we wanted to define what
a platform is and isn't
and
as part of that process i found that a
lot of times platforms are defined like
this as levels of abstraction
uh however it became really clear that
while thinking about platforms as a
level of abstraction is interesting uh
and
uh frequently partially correct it's not
necessarily nuanced enough to help
government decision makers and policy
makers fully understand uh what they are
going to build and implement
it just doesn't tell us enough about the
governance choices that are made during
this development phase um which
is really important when you're thinking
about the checks the scale uh and the
types of change management projects that
a government might be looking at
uh just further not every abstraction
tool should necessarily be considered a
platform uh platform's products and
services all abstract away some part of
the technical infrastructure in some way
uh and platforms tend to have a really
unique uh
sort of feature where you also have
complements that are built on top of
uh that that technical infrastructure
operate within this ecosystem and feed
off each other and so as we're thinking
about building government platforms at
scale it's also really important to
understand um
how platforms can go beyond just
abstraction tools
this uh led to a working definition
of platforms as easy stones
low and hydride components with
specified and stable interfaces through
which one accesses those components this
is a working definition of platforms
that was used in this research
that came from about three dozen
practitioner interviews with folks who
are building a platform in government or
otherwise doing digital government work
uh and a pretty comprehensive literature
review of
relevant topics
uh we've come to this definition uh as
sort of this three-part ecosystem in
which all three of these parts are
equally as important for something to be
considered a platform and if something
doesn't have one of these parts
frequently something might not have uh a
system of high variety components or
complements that operate within this
ecosystem uh it might be an abstraction
tool it might be a really interesting
product that helps governments deliver
services in really interesting ways or
otherwise is quite powerful um but for
the purposes of this research and
thinking through how governments
should be building and operationalizing
platforms it's just one platform
this definition isn't necessarily just
about
what it is
it's designed to give us information and
language that we need uh to have policy
makers and developers work together to
discuss how to build uh the desired
features within these parameters
just to expand on the definition a
little bit to make sure it's really
clear before going into the next part of
the presentation
uh
this definition
sort of at a high level can be matched
to a
component of the
ios operating platform there are low
variety components these highly reusable
elements from ecosystems like ios
um
that sort of
don't change as frequently and are the
core
of the apps and complements both on top
of it there are high variety components
uh sort of the number of components that
are peripheral like applications uh and
there's a stable interface like the app
store through which applications uh can
be marketed on this platform ecosystem
that's what makes the iphone uh sort of
a funny system in a way
that is not true other products and
services
so using uh this definition of platforms
it's interesting to think about how
governments might decide to build a
platforming system and what types of
choices they would need to make to
ensure that they're building
something that's going to meet their end
goal
there are ways to build something that
has high and low variety components and
stable interfaces
uh in a variety of ways that meet not
only the goals of the government but
also the real
and perceived constraints that come with
doing technical work in a government
space
so the things that influence uh how this
how a platform might be built in this
way are
first and primarily uh technical and
policy choices
some of these technical and policy
choices are
should the interface uh be open or
closed uh there are a lot of decisions
that go into
why a government building a platform
ecosystem might want to have
an open or closed interface and that
decision is going to ultimately dictate
how powerful and useful that platform
ecosystem is within the government
for example
uh
a platform that is uh maybe built by the
u.s digital service or by atf uh
might have a
closed interface not because they don't
want to have an
increasingly large number of
applications or
components that sit on top of their
infrastructure
but because there are government
structures that prevent them from
allowing anyone to use
their platform ecosystem to provide
applications and compliments to the
government
uh
you also need to decide if you want this
platform ecosystem to be mandatory or
voluntary
is the white house or
is a centralized government agency going
to build a
sort of shared platform service like
login.gov
um
or
or
the federalist or something like this
and are they going to mandate that that
platform ecosystem is used across the
government uh
if it's mandated then the way that you
might build a government platform
is going to come across differently uh
and going to maybe follow different
structures or technical choices
than if it's voluntary and you're trying
to entice folks to join uh and
transition their existing government uh
infrastructure to your platform
there's also a greater constraint on the
ways that you might charge or fund uh
your platform ecosystem if you're just
going to use it within a single
department uh that
can be built differently uh and thought
of differently than if you're going to
try to use platforms across the entire
government
so this is just an overview of sort of
the variety of technical and policy
choices that go into
the decision to specifically build
platforms within a government ecosystem
there's also this concept that you need
to understand how you would
operationalize a platform
uh
which can be quite different in the
government space than in the private
sector space
the government
the research showed that they were
really three ways that folks
operationalized platforms uh
to be used
uh in in government so you either you
either see people using a platform
ecosystem meaning that they
uh use it within a single department
maybe this really just translates to
someone moving over to aws or azure uh
or some other type of platform that they
either build or buy but is pretty
concentrated within a single
agency or department or program
you could share a platform ecosystem
which really speaks to these shared
services i referenced earlier like
login.gov or cloud.com where something
is built either within a department or
in a centralized area but is really
designed and meant to be shared across
more than just one department or you
could attempt to be a platform ecosystem
which is frequently referred to in the
government space as government as a
platform uh the misnomer of government
as a platform is that it should be the
end goal for governments who are looking
to use platforms as a means to service
delivery
however i feel this is frequently not
the best or the most correct way for a
government to operationalize a platform
approach uh it frequently requires a
much greater leap in technical
capabilities and political power and
influence
and
doesn't necessarily and you know can
prevent all the benefits that could be
achieved from having shared services or
even just from getting departments to
migrate to aws uh which in some cases
would be a great and a great increase in
government service delivery
uh so all of that said there really are
three ways that you might operationalize
uh the platform ecosystem that you
choose and whatever this operational
strategy is it's really going to uh
dictate how the platform
might be built so government as a
platform really needs to have an ease of
integration for broader interpretation
uh and adaption across the entire
government you would want all
departments and agencies to be able to
access that infrastructure and that data
and to build on top of it in a way that
wouldn't be true if you were
just going to migrate a program to the
cloud uh
we're just going to try to get all
departments to adopt the same login dot
system uh login system whiteboarding.com
is attempting to
so
what influences the technical choices
you might make and the operational
choices you might make uh when building
a government platform
this is really i think what makes this
technical work so interesting in the
government space
is because uh there are government
structures that really create a
different set of opportunities and
strengths and weaknesses and this all
changes what's possible
governments have to work within these
structures when thinking about building
platforms in the government uh and
it's important to figure out uh how
these change what's possible and uh how
that constrains what you're going to be
able to build for example budgeting
constraints you might find it more
difficult to
identify funding for a centralized
platform because there won't be as
direct
um impact towards a specific service and
it won't be as easy to identify cost
savings or value of that project
or in some instances in the interviews i
conducted in both the us and the uk
government system specifically we found
that attempting to build a centralized
government platform
resulted in a centralized budgeting
authority saying uh that's great and
that's really interesting
who is going to use it so that we can
take money their budget fund the work
that you're going to do
uh this obviously is a really
challenging way to convince people to
use a tool that you have not built yet
um if they are going to lose money up
front and be committed to whatever you
are going to
provide to them and so there are real
uh structural challenges to the ways
that you would fund a budgeting uh or
budget for a government platform in this
way that could
indicate that you can't do government as
a platform or a shared platform service
right away and you might need to
within a single department
look to just migrate some small programs
of services
onto a platform ecosystem or on uh
inclusive of cloud infrastructure
in a way that can sort of show that
there is progress and that there is a
need and then scale up
that's just one example of how that
government structure plays out in this
way and constrains the type of work that
you can do uh to build and
operationalize platforms in the
government space that same structure
could
uh
really come to fruition in a different
way in a different government space
or even in 15 20 years from now could be
viewed differently in the us or the uk
context another structure that was
really interesting that came up in this
research was the idea of dependencies
and accountability and ownership uh
incentive structures in the government
uh also play out differently than the
private sector and people have a need to
stay connected to the infrastructure
that they're
using uh because they have final
responsibility and accountability to the
executive or to their boss when
something that they're overseeing breaks
this can make it really hard to want to
rely on a shared platform uh or a shared
service and and certainly really
difficult to want to rely on or create
government as a platform
uh in the way that it's frequently
defined
and so you know that might be impossible
to work around or it might require
sort of a shift in the way that we think
about uh government accountability and
incentive structures there's also this
need for political support of course and
that's going to change what is able to
be done
and implemented
it's really the point here is uh
platforms aren't new to government we've
been using platform like concepts uh for
a really long time in the government
space
and government should use platforms
because
uh
there is an increasingly obvious
economic benefits and savings that can
occur when you are able to reduce
um
the redundancies and costs and access
the economies of scale and scope that
come with leveraging platform ecosystems
but the ways that governments can build
platforms
can be different from the private sector
and has to be done in a really really
intentional way
this is because all of the
technical and architectural decisions
made while platforms are being designed
and developed are really
political choices
uh developers and policy makers need to
be on the same page about what they want
a platform to look like
what types of technical decisions need
to be made to allow that platform to do
or to not do
what the government needs
and how they want it to be
operationalized
such that it's being used in the most
correct and efficient way
uh this work can be really hard and
that's why this research primarily
focused on creating some shared language
and a shared definition around what a
government platform might be and what
it's not
uh and
with that i'd just like to end with that
definition being uh that a platform
really is a three-part system of high
and low volatility components uh that
are accessed through stable interfaces
and
as governments start to coalesce around
sort of a shared definition
like this or
um or something else that allows
developers and policy makers to have a
shared language around what exactly
should be implemented
we'll be able to really move forward in
thinking through
uh what a government platform strategy
should be and how government platforms
can improve uh
both service delivery to constituents
and internal government operations
thanks so much uh like i said at the
beginning i'm really interested in this
research and i've been working on this
uh for quite a long time both at the
harvard kennedy school and with
microsoft um and would really be
interested to continue the conversation
uh with folks that are interested or
that have questions um and to expand
upon what has really been a condensed
presentation to fit this conference
framework uh and would be happy to share
the full report or to talk in greater
length and detail about how we came to
these definitions um and who we talked
to to come to these definitions
and really how we
have thought about the technical and
operational choices influenced by those
government structures that
define and constrain what's possible
when thinking about building government
platforms in the public sector thanks so
much